one contestant is sent packing and
another is named a miracle man on night
one of the Dancing with the Stars finale
never ever seen a more intelligent
artistic passionate creative and well
danced freestyle that had everything and
more you are the miracle man of season
23 as the quest for the mirror ball
trophy comes to an end james hinchcliffe
and pro partner Sharna Burgess stunned
the judges and the crowd with an
emotional freestyle based off his
terrible racing accident in 2015 I
remember entering turn three and then
everything goes black
but the couple was surprisingly in the
bottom two of the night the couple
leaving right now is Jenna and led et
spoke with the pair after their
elimination I had the most incredible
journey it's and it's not like there's
another week so it's like it's great I
mean we killed it every week and two
days of redemption down of the Freestyle
totally killed it I was sick I'm so sick
no joke he's great he was an amazing
partner we just every week we went out
there we did everything we could are we
supposed to be friends yeah yeah yeah
the final three lorien Val Calvin and
Lindsey as well as James and Sharna will
dance it out in the ballroom Tuesday
night and we can't wait to see who takes
the mirror ball home let us know who
you're rooting for over on twitter at ET
now
you